Prescription products require completion of an online medication consultation with an independent health care provider through the LifeMD platform and are only available if prescribed. Subscription required. Individual results may vary. Additional restrictions apply at LifeMD.com. Read all warnings before using GLP-1s. Side effects may include a risk of thyroid C-cell tumors. Do not use GLP-1s if you or your family have a history of thyroid cancer. If you've struggled for years to lose weight and have given up hope, did you know you can now access GLP-1 prescription medications through LifeMD?
处方产品需要通过LifeMD平台与独立的医疗保健提供者完成在线用药咨询，且仅在开具处方后方可提供。需要订阅。个人结果可能有所不同。更多限制条件请见LifeMD.com。使用GLP-1药物前请阅读所有警告。副作用可能包括甲状腺C细胞肿瘤风险。如果您或您的家人有甲状腺癌病史，请勿使用GLP-1药物。如果您多年来一直为减肥而挣扎并已放弃希望，您是否知道现在可以通过LifeMD获得GLP-1处方药物？
LifeMD is now offering eligible patients online access to GLP-1s, the breakthrough prescription medication that can help you lose body fat and weight. Listen to what people are saying. You just take your shot. It doesn't feel like you're on a diet. What I wasn't expecting it to do was to shut off the food noise. This was life altering, and if I can do it, I feel like anybody can do it. And here's the best part. Your was life altering and if I can do it, I feel like anybody can do it. And here's the best part, your insurance may cover 100% of the cost of your medication. So go to TryLifeMD.com to have your eligibility checked right now. Get started today at TryLifeMD.com. That's T-R-Y-L-I-F-E-M-D.com. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents.
LifeMD现在为符合条件的患者提供GLP-1的在线获取渠道，这是一种突破性的处方药，可以帮助您减少身体脂肪和体重。听听人们是怎么说的。你只需要注射。感觉不像是在节食。我没预料到它能消除对食物的渴望。这改变了我的生活，如果我能做到，我觉得任何人都能做到。最棒的部分是，您的保险可能会支付100%的药费。所以请访问TryLifeMD.com立即检查您的资格。今天就开始行动，访问TryLifeMD.com。网址是T-R-Y-L-I-F-E-M-D.com。我们的剧集涉及严重且通常令人痛苦的事件。
If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Today's episode involves crimes against children and won't be suitable for all listeners. for all listeners. Over the Memorial Day weekend in late March 2004, seven-year-old Emily Higgs left her bright pink bicycle outside her home in Greybull, Indiana. When she went to retrieve it, she noticed someone had left a Ziploc plastic bag in the bike's front basket. Inside the bag
如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用程序或我们网站上的本集节目说明。今天的剧集涉及针对儿童的犯罪，并不适合所有听众。2004年3月下旬的阵亡将士纪念日周末，七岁的艾米丽·希格斯（Emily Higgs）将她那辆亮粉色的自行车留在了印第安纳州格雷布尔（Greybull）的家门外。当她去取车时，她注意到有人在自行车的前篮里留下了一个Ziploc塑料袋。袋子里
was an anonymous note written in pencil on lined yellow paper. It read, Hi honey, I've been watching you. I am the same person that kidnapped and raped and killed April Tinsley. You are my next victim. If you don't report this to police, or I don't see this in the paper tomorrow or on the local news, I will blow up your house, killing everyone but you. You will be mine." The plastic bag also contained a used condom. The plastic bag also contained a used condom. Emily took the items to her mother, Crystal. While Crystal was unsettled, she was convinced it was a sick joke, possibly the handiwork of one of her teenage son's friends. The author's handwriting was messy and childlike. It was also riddled with grammatical punctuation and spelling errors, with simple words like
是一张用铅笔写在黄色横线纸上的匿名纸条。上面写着：“亲爱的，我一直在看着你。我就是那个绑架、强奸并杀害了艾普丽尔·廷斯利（April Tinsley）的人。你是我的下一个受害者。如果你不向警察报告这件事，或者我明天在报纸或当地新闻上没看到报道，我就炸掉你的房子，杀光除了你以外的所有人。你会是我的。”塑料袋里还装有一个用过的避孕套。塑料袋里还装有一个用过的避孕套。艾米丽把这些东西拿给了她的母亲克里斯托（Crystal）。虽然克里斯托感到不安，但她确信这只是一个恶作剧，可能是她十几岁儿子的朋友干的。作者的笔迹凌乱且幼稚。而且充满了语法、标点和拼写错误，简单的单词如
will misspelled as W-E-L-L. The name April Tinsley didn't ring any bells for Crystal Higgs, whose family had only been living in the area for a couple of years. But when she told a long-time community member about the disturbing message, they were visibly shaken. They told Crystal, You need to call the sheriff and have him come out. Schools across Indiana closed early on April 1 1988 on account of it being Good Friday, a Christian holiday that marks the start of the Easter break. April Tinsley, who had recently celebrated her eighth birthday
“will”被拼写成了“W-E-L-L”。“艾普丽尔·廷斯利”这个名字对克里斯托·希格斯来说并不熟悉，她的家人在该地区只住了几年。但当她告诉一位社区老居民这个令人不安的信息时，对方明显感到震惊。他们告诉克里斯托：“你需要报警，让警长过来。”1988年4月1日，印第安纳州各地的学校因耶稣受难日（Good Friday）提前放学，这是一个标志着复活节假期开始的基督教节日。艾普丽尔·廷斯利，刚庆祝完八岁生日
and was in the first grade, left Fairfield Elementary at 11.30am. She returned to her family's home on West Williams Street in the city of Fort Wayne. It had been a cold and dreary morning, so when a break in the weather arrived early that afternoon, April sought to make the most of it. She asked her mother Janet if she could go out and play with her friend Nicole, who lived just a few blocks away on West Suttonfield Street. April had walked to and from Nicole's house many times before. Janet said yes, but told April to call home as soon as she got to Nicole's to confirm she'd arrived safely. After lunch, Janet handed April an umbrella and sent her on her way. A short while later, the Tinsley's phone rang. It was April calling to check in as promised.
并且上一年级，于上午11点30分离开了费尔菲尔德小学（Fairfield Elementary）。她回到了位于韦恩堡（Fort Wayne）西威廉姆斯街的家中。那天早上寒冷而阴沉，所以当那天下午早些时候天气放晴时，艾普丽尔想充分利用这段时间。她问母亲珍妮特（Janet）是否可以出去和住在几个街区外西萨顿菲尔德街的朋友妮可（Nicole）一起玩。艾普丽尔以前曾多次步行往返于妮可家。珍妮特答应了，但告诉艾普丽尔一到妮可家就打电话回家确认她已安全到达。午饭后，珍妮特递给艾普丽尔一把雨伞，送她出门。不久后，廷斯利家的电话响了。是艾普丽尔打来电话报平安，正如她承诺的那样。
Before hanging up, Janet reminded April to be home by 4pm to avoid the rain that had been forecast. I got my umbrella, April playfully replied. When April failed to return home on time, Janet Tinsley called Nicole's house seeking an explanation. She learned that April and Nicole had spent most of the afternoon playing with dolls and excitedly discussing all the chocolate they planned to collect over Easter. The girls then walked to a playground halfway between their homes where they met up with another friend. Nicole said they'd left the playground a little after 3pm to go to the third friend's house, which was close by. As the girls walked together, it began to drizzle. Realising she had left her umbrella at Nicole's house, April decided to quickly go back there and get it. The others continued on to their destination,
挂断电话前，珍妮特提醒艾普丽尔在下午4点前回家，以避开预报中的降雨。“我带了伞，”艾普丽尔俏皮地回答。当艾普丽尔没能按时回家时，珍妮特·廷斯利打电话给妮可家询问原因。她得知艾普丽尔和妮可大部分下午都在玩洋娃娃，并兴奋地讨论着她们计划在复活节收集的所有巧克力。随后，女孩们步行到她们家中间的一个游乐场，在那里遇到了另一个朋友。妮可说她们在下午3点多一点离开了游乐场，去附近第三个朋友的家。当女孩们一起走时，开始下起了毛毛雨。意识到自己把伞落在了妮可家，艾普丽尔决定快速回去取。其他人继续前往她们的目的地，
and when April didn't join them, Nicole assumed she decided to go home instead. When Nicole's mother told Janet Tinsley, April never did come back here to get her umbrella. Janet felt the blood rush from her body. She was overcome with the feeling that something was very wrong. Janet alerted her husband Michael and they immediately began walking the streets looking for April. She was a carefree child and they knew her to be a little silly with her favourite game being hide and seek. They were also mindful that it was April Fool's Day. Maybe April was playing some kind of prank on them. Yet as time wore on with no sign of April, Janet and Michael grew increasingly anxious. At 6pm, Janet tearfully reported her daughter's disappearance to police. Officers arrived at the Tinsley home where April lived with her mother, father, and infant brother.
当艾普丽尔没有加入她们时，妮可以为她决定直接回家了。当妮可的母亲告诉珍妮特·廷斯利：“艾普丽尔根本没回来拿伞”时，珍妮特感到浑身血液倒流。她被一种非常不祥的预感所笼罩。珍妮特惊动了她的丈夫迈克尔（Michael），他们立即开始在街上寻找艾普丽尔。她是一个无忧无虑的孩子，他们知道她有点调皮，最喜欢的游戏是捉迷藏。他们也意识到那天是愚人节。也许艾普丽尔是在跟他们开某种玩笑。然而，随着时间流逝，仍不见艾普丽尔的踪影，珍妮特和迈克尔变得越来越焦虑。下午6点，珍妮特含泪向警方报告了女儿的失踪。警察赶到了廷斯利家，艾普丽尔与她的母亲、父亲和婴儿弟弟住在这里。
For as long as Janet could remember, she had always wanted to be a mother. In her teens, she often told people that her first child was going to be a girl with blue eyes and curly blonde hair, and her name would be April Marie. Janet's dreams came true on March 18, 1980, when April was born. A cheerful child, April always had a smile on her face and loved to make others laugh, but she was also shy and typically stayed close to her mother. Her parents adored and doted on her. Losing her was devastating. The police were sympathetic towards the Tinsleys and took their concerns seriously. They immediately started retracing April's last known movements, carrying a photo of her to aid in their search.
在珍妮特的记忆中，她一直想成为一名母亲。十几岁时，她经常告诉别人，她的第一个孩子会是一个有着蓝眼睛和卷曲金发的女孩，名字叫艾普丽尔·玛丽（April Marie）。1980年3月18日，当艾普丽尔出生时，珍妮特的梦想成真了。艾普丽尔是一个开朗的孩子，脸上总是挂着笑容，喜欢逗别人笑，但她也很害羞，通常待在母亲身边。她的父母非常疼爱她。失去她令人心碎。警方对廷斯利一家表示同情，并认真对待他们的担忧。他们立即开始重走艾普丽尔最后已知的路线，带着她的照片以协助搜寻。
They were also given a description of what April was wearing that day – a blue turtleneck sweater with a pink and red jacket over the top, a pair of light blue pants with three love hearts down one leg, and pink gym shoes. The area April had been walking covered only a few blocks, which she'd navigated many times before. Houses were door-knocked and residents questioned. Every garage, alley, and abandoned building was checked, but April was nowhere to be found. The search radius expanded into the city's rural outskirts. Soon, many volunteers were assisting police in their search. As news of April's disappearance spread, a local resident came forward to report an incident they'd seen earlier that day. At around the time April went missing, they saw a little girl walking along Hoagland Avenue,
他们还得到了艾普丽尔当天穿着的描述——一件蓝色高领毛衣，外面套着一件粉红色和红色的夹克，一条浅蓝色裤子，一条腿上有三个爱心图案，还有粉红色的运动鞋。艾普丽尔行走的区域只有几个街区，她以前曾多次走过。警察敲开了每家每户的门进行询问。每一个车库、小巷和废弃建筑都被检查过，但艾普丽尔无处可寻。搜寻半径扩大到了城市的农村郊区。很快，许多志愿者协助警方进行搜寻。随着艾普丽尔失踪的消息传开，一位当地居民站出来报告了当天早些时候看到的一起事件。在艾普丽尔失踪的时间左右，他们看到一个小女孩沿着霍格兰大道（Hoagland Avenue）行走，
a long suburban street that led to April's home. As the little girl crossed the street, a shabby blue pickup truck pulled up alongside her. The witness glimpsed the man behind the wheel. He appeared nonchalant and the girl seemed equally unfazed. When the pick-upper drove off, the girl was gone. The witness didn't see or hear a struggle, so they assumed the driver was the girl's father. They described what they remembered about the girl, specifically the light blue pants she'd been wearing that featured several distinctive love hearts trailing down one leg. Investigators were certain the witness had seen April Tinsley at the exact moment she was taken. The pick-up driver was described as a white man in his 30s. He had wavy, sandy-coloured hair with darker roots and a few days worth of beard growth.
这是一条通往艾普丽尔家的长长的郊区街道。当小女孩过马路时，一辆破旧的蓝色皮卡车停在她身边。目击者瞥见了驾驶座上的男人。他看起来很冷漠，女孩似乎也同样镇定。当皮卡车开走时，女孩不见了。目击者没有看到或听到挣扎，所以他们以为司机是女孩的父亲。他们描述了对女孩的记忆，特别是她穿着的那条浅蓝色裤子，腿上印着几个独特的爱心。调查人员确信目击者在艾普丽尔被带走的瞬间看到了她。皮卡车司机被描述为一名30多岁的白人男子。他留着波浪状的沙色头发，发根颜色较深，留着几天的胡茬。
Seemingly, no one knew him. While crime wasn't unheard of in Fort Wayne, child abduction was. It had been over a decade since the last case of that nature. The thought that a child could be snatched off the street in broad daylight led to local parents experiencing anxieties they'd never felt before. As night fell and April remained missing, police settled on a worst-case scenario. They put out an all-points bulletin for April, certain she had indeed been taken. The frantic search continued and the community remained vigilant, fearful the perpetrator would strike again. Over that weekend, a dozen police officers
似乎没有人认识他。虽然韦恩堡并非没有犯罪，但儿童绑架案却很少见。距离上一次此类案件已经过去十多年了。一个孩子在光天化日之下从街上被抢走的想法，让当地父母经历了他们从未感受过的焦虑。夜幕降临，艾普丽尔依然失踪，警方确定了最坏的情况。他们发布了针对艾普丽尔的全面通报，确信她确实被带走了。疯狂的搜寻仍在继续，社区保持警惕，担心肇事者会再次作案。那个周末，十几名警察
worked a collective 200 hours on the investigation, but Easter passed with no breakthroughs. On the afternoon of Monday April 4, a male jogger was running along County Road 68 in Spencerville, a small unincorporated rural community 20 miles northeast of Fort Wayne. As he passed by remote farming fields and dense woodland, he spotted something in a rain-swollen drainage ditch 40 feet from the roadside. It was the body of April Tinsley. April had been suffocated and strangled to death. Although she was fully clothed in the outfit she'd had on when she went missing, it was clear she'd been redressed after being sexually assaulted. Her pants were on
在调查中总共工作了200个小时，但复活节过去了，没有任何突破。4月4日星期一的下午，一名男性慢跑者沿着印第安纳州斯彭瑟维尔（Spencerville）的68号县道跑步，这是一个位于韦恩堡东北20英里的一个小型非建制农村社区。当他经过偏远的农田和茂密的林地时，他发现路边40英尺外的一条雨水充盈的排水沟里有什么东西。那是艾普丽尔·廷斯利的尸体。艾普丽尔是被窒息和勒死的。虽然她穿着失踪时穿的那套衣服，但很明显她在被性侵后被重新穿上了衣服。她的裤子是
backwards and she was missing a shoe. No foreign genetic matter was found on April's body, but testing of her underwear revealed traces of semen. In 1988, the role of DNA in criminal investigations was a relatively new and unknown concept. But by chance, in the days before April was murdered, Fort Wayne Detectives had completed a workshop on DNA evidence. It taught them how to correctly collect and store April's killer's DNA to ensure its integrity and longevity. DNA testing at the time required a large sample to obtain the subject's profile. The minuscule amount recovered from April's underwear, coupled with limitations in forensic technology, prevented authorities from gleaning March.
反着穿的，而且少了一只鞋。艾普丽尔的尸体上没有发现外源性遗传物质，但对她内衣的检测显示有精液痕迹。1988年，DNA在刑事调查中的作用是一个相对较新且未知的概念。但巧合的是，在艾普丽尔被谋杀的前几天，韦恩堡的侦探们刚刚完成了一个关于DNA证据的研讨会。它教会了他们如何正确收集和储存艾普丽尔杀手的DNA，以确保其完整性和长期保存。当时的DNA检测需要大量样本才能获得主体的图谱。从艾普丽尔内衣中提取的微量样本，加上法医技术的局限性，使当局无法获得更多信息。
Still, they respected its significance as a means of positively confirming April's killer once they had him in custody. It would remain their one crucial piece of evidence as a thorough search of the crime scene and its surroundings failed to uncover anything that immediately identified April's killer. Because no effort was made to conceal April's remains, detectives knew they were dealing with an attention seeker who wanted his crime to be discovered. The killer seemed to have an inflated sense of confidence that he wouldn't be found, yet he wasn't entirely devoid of fear. April's missing shoe was eventually found around 1000 feet west of her body on the other side of the road. Police suspected April's killer had dumped her in the ditch, then realised as he
尽管如此，他们尊重其作为在将杀手拘留后确凿确认其身份的手段的重要性。这将仍然是他们唯一关键的证据，因为对犯罪现场及其周围环境的彻底搜查未能发现任何能立即识别艾普丽尔杀手的东西。由于没有试图掩盖艾普丽尔的遗体，侦探们知道他们面对的是一个寻求关注、希望自己的罪行被发现的人。杀手似乎有一种膨胀的自信，认为自己不会被发现，但他并非完全没有恐惧。艾普丽尔丢失的那只鞋最终在路对面她尸体以西约1000英尺处被发现。警方怀疑艾普丽尔的杀手把她扔在沟里，然后意识到当他
drove off that one of her shoes was still in his vehicle. Scared of being seen if he returned to the dump site, he tossed the shoe out a window as he sped away. A medical examiner concluded that April had been killed one or two days prior to the discovery of her body. County Road 68 was not the kind of place someone from out of town would be aware of, have a reason to visit or happen to come across. The killer must have been familiar with it and knew that his chances of being spotted there were slim. This meant he was likely from Fort Wayne or one of its surrounding townships. No one sprang to mind as a suspect. The Tinsleys had no enemies and couldn't imagine who would want to harm their daughter. Known sex offenders who lived in the
开车离开时，她的一只鞋还在车里。因为害怕如果回到抛尸现场会被人看到，他在加速离开时把鞋从窗户扔了出去。法医得出结论，艾普丽尔在尸体被发现前一两天被杀。68号县道不是外地人会知道、有理由去或偶然经过的地方。杀手一定很熟悉那里，并且知道他在那里被发现的可能性很小。这意味着他很可能来自韦恩堡或其周边乡镇。没有人被认为是嫌疑人。廷斯利一家没有敌人，无法想象谁会想伤害他们的女儿。住在
crimes of vicinity were questioned by police but were gradually ruled out as having any involvement. When word reached to detectives that there was an alleged sighting of a blue pickup truck near where April's body was found, they took notice. That was the same type of vehicle April's abductor had apparently been driving. Police examined thousands of blue pick-up trucks across Indiana, but nothing of value was uncovered. A suspect sketch of the driver depicted a generic looking white man, but Crimestoppers was inundated with calls from people who thought they knew him. 140 of these calls implicated a 34-year-old named Everett Schull Jr. Schull was a local gang member known as Moose. When shown a photographic line-up featuring Schull,
附近的已知性犯罪者受到了警方的盘问，但逐渐被排除在嫌疑之外。当侦探们收到消息称有人在艾普丽尔尸体被发现的地方附近看到了蓝色皮卡车时，他们注意到了。那正是艾普丽尔绑架者显然驾驶的那种车辆。警方检查了印第安纳州各地的数千辆蓝色皮卡车，但没有发现任何有价值的线索。嫌疑人的素描描绘了一个长相普通的白人男子，但犯罪举报热线（Crimestoppers）被那些认为自己认识他的人打来的电话淹没了。其中140个电话指向了一名34岁名叫埃弗雷特·舒尔（Everett Schull Jr.）的男子。舒尔是当地一个被称为“驼鹿”（Moose）的帮派成员。当向目击者展示包含舒尔的照片排队时，
the eyewitness from Hoagland Avenue identified him as April's abductor. Upon speaking with Shull's neighbour, detectives learnt that for several weeks there had been a blue pickup truck parked outside of Shull's home. While Shull didn't own such a vehicle, he had access to one through a friend. Schull was also known to loiter around parks and make crude remarks about children. He had been accused of molesting an 11-year-old girl, though the case was ultimately dropped. Days before April Tinsley was taken, Schull was allegedly overheard telling another person that he'd seen two girls playing and that he wanted to grab one of them. The gang Everett Scholl Jr. belonged to had an interest in the occult,
来自霍格兰大道的目击者认出他就是艾普丽尔的绑架者。在与舒尔的邻居交谈时，侦探们得知几周来舒尔家门外一直停着一辆蓝色皮卡车。虽然舒尔没有这样的车，但他可以通过朋友使用一辆。舒尔还以在公园附近徘徊并对儿童发表粗俗言论而闻名。他曾被指控猥亵一名11岁女孩，尽管该案最终被撤销。在艾普丽尔·廷斯利被带走的前几天，据称有人听到舒尔告诉另一个人，他看到两个女孩在玩耍，他想抓住其中一个。埃弗雷特·舒尔所属的帮派对神秘学感兴趣，
prompting rumours that April's murder was some type of ritualistic sacrifice. While this theory became a hot topic amongst the gossiping locals, police concluded that it had no merit. Schull denied knowing anything about April Tinsley. He passed several polygraph tests, and when his DNA didn't match the sample from April's assailant, he was released. DNA samples from four additional suspects were tested, only to be ruled out. DNA samples from four additional suspects were tested, only to be ruled out. Detectives continued to investigate the hundreds of tips that came in from suspicious men seen around the neighbourhood to others who had recently changed their appearance. Whenever a new lead emerged, police dropped everything to pursue it. Each time, they reached a dead end. In the immediate aftermath of April's murder,
引发了艾普丽尔的谋杀是某种仪式性献祭的传言。虽然这一理论成为当地人闲聊的热门话题，但警方得出结论，它毫无根据。舒尔否认知道关于艾普丽尔·廷斯利的任何事情。他通过了几次测谎仪测试，当他的DNA与艾普丽尔袭击者的样本不匹配时，他被释放了。另外四名嫌疑人的DNA样本也经过了测试，但都被排除了。另外四名嫌疑人的DNA样本也经过了测试，但都被排除了。侦探们继续调查从社区周围看到的形迹可疑的男子到最近改变外貌的人那里收到的数百条线索。每当出现新线索时，警方都会放下一切去追查。但每一次，他们都走进了死胡同。在艾普丽尔谋杀案发生后的第一时间，
the community struggled to return to any sense of normalcy. Children now walked in groups and police patrolled streets near schools. Ninety locals formed a group called April, which stood for Abduction Prevention Reconnaissance and Information League. Members ranged in age from 14 to 52 and their aims were to keep children safe, raise money for victims of crime and educate young people on the importance of avoiding strangers. The group's president insisted that they weren't vigilantes, they were just ensuring another tragedy didn't occur.
社区努力恢复正常。孩子们现在成群结队地行走，警察在学校附近的街道上巡逻。90名当地人组成了一个名为APRIL的组织，代表“绑架预防侦察与信息联盟”（Abduction Prevention Reconnaissance and Information League）。成员年龄从14岁到52岁不等，他们的目标是保护儿童安全，为犯罪受害者筹集资金，并教育年轻人避免与陌生人接触的重要性。该组织的主席坚称他们不是治安维持者，他们只是确保不再发生悲剧。
And it seemed like their efforts paid off. Two years passed without any further attacks. In late May 1990, a teenage boy who lived on the northeastern rural outskirts of Fort Wayne noticed something peculiar going on. Someone had been lingering around his family's barn. The barn was just a few feet from a thoroughfare named Schwartz Road and backed onto a large, secluded field. The teen had gone to the barn and noticed a handwritten message scrawled across the white, weather-beaten planks of its exterior doors which faced the road. The message had been written in pencil, so it wasn't very clear. On several
看起来他们的努力得到了回报。两年过去了，没有发生进一步的袭击。1990年5月下旬，一名住在韦恩堡东北农村郊区的十几岁男孩注意到了一些奇怪的事情。有人一直在他家谷仓附近徘徊。谷仓距离一条名为施瓦茨路（Schwartz Road）的交通要道仅几英尺，背靠着一大片僻静的田野。这名少年去谷仓时，注意到在面向道路的白色、饱经风霜的谷仓外门上潦草地写着一条手写信息。信息是用铅笔写的，所以不太清楚。在接下来的几天里，
occasions over the following days, the teenager returned to the barn. With each visit, the writing on the door grew progressively darker and more legible. It seemed the author was returning periodically to write over their message. At first, they used a white crayon which still wasn't visible enough to read. The next time, the message had been scribbled over with a black marker. Now, the writing was clear. I kill April Marie Tisley, the message read. I kill again. Unnerved, the teenager phoned the police. It appeared as though the message was left by a child or someone with the mentality of one. Their handwriting, grammar and punctuation were poor.
这名少年多次回到谷仓。每次访问，门上的字迹都变得越来越深、越来越清晰。看来作者定期回来重写他们的信息。起初，他们用的是白色蜡笔，依然不够清晰，无法阅读。下一次，信息被黑色记号笔涂抹过。现在，字迹清晰了。“我杀了艾普丽尔·玛丽·廷斯利，”信息写道。“我还会再杀。”感到不安的少年报了警。看起来这条信息是由一个孩子或具有孩子心态的人留下的。他们的笔迹、语法和标点都很差。
They'd also incorrectly spelled April's surname by forgetting the N and ended their message with the juvenile words, ha ha. It seemed anybody could have written it as a prank or to stir up a drama. But there was one aspect to the message that gave investigators pause. Above the mocking laughter, the author had written, Did you find the other shoe? Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Casefile is thrilled to announce that all five Casefile Presents series, The Detective's Dilemma, The Vanishing of Vivian Cameron, Labyrinth, Searching for Sarah McDermid and Maddie, once exclusive to Spotify, are now accessible on all podcast platforms. These Casefile Presents series feature stories from various corners of the globe told by
他们还拼错了艾普丽尔的姓氏，漏掉了N，并以幼稚的“哈哈”结束了他们的信息。看起来任何人都可以把它写成恶作剧或制造戏剧性事件。但信息中有一个方面让调查人员停了下来。在嘲讽的笑声上方，作者写道：“你找到另一只鞋了吗？”Casefile节目稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。Casefile很高兴地宣布，所有五个Casefile Presents系列——《侦探的困境》（The Detective's Dilemma）、《薇薇安·卡梅伦的失踪》（The Vanishing of Vivian Cameron）、《迷宫》（Labyrinth）、《寻找莎拉·麦克德米德》（Searching for Sarah McDermid）和《麦迪》（Maddie），曾经是Spotify独家内容，现在可以在所有播客平台上访问。这些Casefile Presents系列讲述了来自全球各地的故事，由
different narrators. Through its narratives, Casefile aims to bring these cases and instances of wrongdoing to the forefront, sparking awareness and helping the victims and their families to be remembered. Listen to the previously exclusive Casefile Presents series now, wherever you get your podcasts. I want to tell you about Buried Bones, the historical true crime podcast on the Exactly Right Network. It's hosted by journalist Kate Winkler Dawson and retired investigator Paul Holes. Case file listeners might recognise the name Paul Holes from our six-part East Area rapist to Golden State Killer series. Paul was instrumental in
不同的叙述者讲述。通过这些叙述，Casefile旨在将这些案件和不法行为推向最前沿，激发人们的意识，并帮助受害者及其家人被铭记。现在，无论您在哪里获取播客，都可以收听之前独家的Casefile Presents系列。我想向您介绍《埋骨》（Buried Bones），这是Exactly Right Network上的历史真实犯罪播客。它由记者凯特·温克勒·道森（Kate Winkler Dawson）和退休调查员保罗·霍尔斯（Paul Holes）主持。Casefile的听众可能从我们六部分的《东区强奸犯到金州杀手》（East Area Rapist to Golden State Killer）系列中认出保罗·霍尔斯这个名字。保罗在
identifying Joseph D'Angelo as the perpetrator and was interviewed as part of that series. Each week Paul and Cade examine a different case from history and use their years of experience and 21st century forensics to bring new insights into these very old tragedies. forensics to bring new insights into these very old tragedies. Some cases are still cold and others have been resolved, but was the right person held accountable? Together, Kate and Paul break down these cases, discuss evidence and reflect on how far we've come thanks to modern forensics. Don't miss new episodes every Wednesday. Follow Buried Bones wherever you get your podcasts. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content.
确定约瑟夫·迪安杰洛（Joseph D'Angelo）为肇事者方面发挥了重要作用，并作为该系列的一部分接受了采访。每周，保罗和凯特都会审视一个不同的历史案件，并利用他们多年的经验和21世纪的法医技术，为这些非常古老的悲剧带来新的见解。有些案件仍然是悬案，有些已经解决，但被追究责任的人是正确的吗？凯特和保罗一起剖析这些案件，讨论证据，并反思由于现代法医技术，我们已经走了多远。不要错过每周三的新剧集。无论您在哪里获取播客，请关注《埋骨》。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。
By this time, all of the detectives originally assigned to the Tinsley case had been taken off to focus on other work. While the case remained open and new tips were explored, the investigation had definitely stagnated. April's killer had seemingly fallen off the face of the earth, leaving authorities to assume that he'd fled elsewhere, died, or was somehow incapacitated and prevented from being a threat. The barn message completely shattered this theory and left detectives rattled. The Schwartz Road barn was located roughly 10 miles from where April's body was discovered.
到这个时候，最初分配给廷斯利案的所有侦探都已被调离去处理其他工作。虽然案件仍然开放，新的线索也在探索中，但调查确实停滞了。艾普丽尔的杀手似乎从地球上消失了，这让当局认为他已经逃往别处、死亡，或者以某种方式丧失了能力，不再构成威胁。谷仓上的信息彻底粉碎了这一理论，让侦探们感到不安。施瓦茨路的谷仓距离艾普丽尔尸体被发现的地方大约10英里。
The fact that she was found without one of her shoes, which was discarded further down the road, was a detail investigators had kept close to their chest. They had never shared it with the media or the public and so it was never reported on or widely known. This meant that the barn message must have been written by April's killer. After two quiet years, he had returned with the intention to kill again. A search of the barn and its surrounds came up dry, save for a few crayons strewn across the ground below the message. These were tested for fingerprints, but none were recovered. And the teenager who reported the message never saw the person who wrote it. Yet it had given detectives greater insight into the perpetrator's psyche. His message was intended to mock, torment and provoke them.
她被发现时少了一只鞋，而那只鞋被丢弃在更远的路边，这一细节调查人员一直守口如瓶。他们从未与媒体或公众分享过，因此从未被报道或广为人知。这意味着谷仓上的信息一定是艾普丽尔的杀手写的。在平静了两年之后，他带着再次杀人的意图回来了。对谷仓及其周围环境的搜查一无所获，除了信息下方散落在地上的几支蜡笔。这些蜡笔被检测是否有指纹，但没有发现。而报告该信息的少年从未见过写下它的人。然而，它让侦探们对肇事者的心理有了更深入的了解。他的信息旨在嘲弄、折磨和挑衅他们。
In the words of one case detective, it was a slap in the face to all the investigators and to the Tinsley family and to April. It made me mad. It made us all very upset. It was clear to investigators that the killer relished in spreading fear and gaining notoriety. He avoided leaving any clues as to his identity and made sure he stayed out of sight. This was someone who spent a lot of time strategising. Even his terrible writing was deemed to be deliberate. Detectives surmised that the killer intentionally wrote poorly so they couldn't identify him and would instead think he was young or had a developmental delay. But his carefully plotted
用一位案件侦探的话说，这是对所有调查人员、廷斯利一家和艾普丽尔的“一记耳光”。“这让我很生气。这让我们所有人都非常不安。”调查人员很清楚，杀手喜欢散布恐惧并获得恶名。他避免留下任何关于他身份的线索，并确保自己不被发现。这是一个花了很多时间制定策略的人。甚至他糟糕的字迹也被认为是故意的。侦探们推测，杀手故意写得很差，这样他们就无法识别他，反而会认为他很年轻或有发育迟缓。但他的精心策划
actions indicated otherwise. Investigators had no choice but to go public with the sample of the barn message to generate leads. They knew that by doing so they were playing right into the killer's hands by giving him the publicity he craved. But detectives were more concerned that if he wasn't caught he could make good on his threat to kill again. The writing sample elicited a few tip-offs. They didn't lead anywhere. A few weeks later on Wednesday June 13 1990, 7-year-old Sarah Bowker was enjoying the pool at her family's apartment complex at Stonepoint Village
的行为表明并非如此。调查人员别无选择，只能公开谷仓信息的样本以产生线索。他们知道，这样做正中杀手下怀，给了他所渴望的宣传。但侦探们更担心的是，如果他不被抓住，他可能会兑现再次杀人的威胁。字迹样本引出了一些举报。但它们没有带来任何结果。几周后的1990年6月13日星期三，7岁的莎拉·鲍克（Sarah Bowker）正在她家位于斯通波因特村（Stonepoint Village）的公寓大楼的游泳池里玩耍
in Fort Wayne. At around 3.30pm, after playing in the water with her stepsister, Sarah headed off alone to visit a friend who also lived in the complex. When Sarah didn't return home for dinner that night, her parents contacted the police. It emerged that Sarah had never reached her friend's apartment, having seemingly vanished somewhere along the short and simple journey. The Balka family were certain Sarah had been forcibly taken, as she had been afraid of strangers ever since the abduction and murder of April Tinsley two years earlier. If a car ever drove slowly towards her, Sarah would run to safety and say, there's a kidnapper out there. Sarah was only one year younger than April and bore a striking resemblance to her.
在韦恩堡。下午3点30分左右，在与继姐妹在水中玩耍后，莎拉独自前往拜访也住在大楼里的朋友。当莎拉那天晚上没有回家吃晚饭时，她的父母联系了警察。事实证明，莎拉从未到达她朋友的公寓，似乎在短暂而简单的旅途中消失了。鲍克一家确信莎拉是被强行带走的，因为自从两年前艾普丽尔·廷斯利被绑架和谋杀以来，她一直害怕陌生人。如果有一辆车慢慢地向她开来，莎拉会跑到安全的地方说：“外面有绑架者。”莎拉只比艾普丽尔小一岁，长相与她惊人地相似。
Given the threat April's killer had scribbled on the barn three weeks earlier, police feared the worst. Multiple squads were called in to search for Sarah. When they failed to find any sign of her, a police dog was brought to the scene. The dog picked up Sarah's scent and followed it south of her apartment complex towards Coldwater Road, leading police to a stuffed toy kitten. The toy belonged to Sarah. In a drainage ditch on the side of the road, searchers found Sarah's body. Sarah's clothing was in disarray and it was clear she had been sexually assaulted. Her cause of death was suffocation as a result of having her face shoved down in the mud. This appeared to have been done in an effort to keep her quiet. It had taken 16 hours to find Sarah and in the hour before discovery, the area had
鉴于艾普丽尔的杀手三周前在谷仓上写下的威胁，警方担心最坏的情况。多个小队被召集来搜寻莎拉。当他们没有发现她的任何踪迹时，警犬被带到了现场。警犬闻到了莎拉的气味，并沿着她公寓大楼的南边向冷水路（Coldwater Road）追踪，将警察带到了一个毛绒玩具小猫处。这个玩具属于莎拉。在路边的排水沟里，搜寻人员发现了莎拉的尸体。莎拉的衣服凌乱不堪，很明显她受到了性侵。她的死因是由于脸被按在泥里而导致的窒息。这似乎是为了让她保持安静。找到莎拉花了16个小时，而在发现前的一小时，该地区
been pelted with heavy rain. If there had been any foreign hairs, fibers or DNA on or around her body, they'd washed away by now. Witness accounts weren't any more helpful. There were reports of an elderly man near the pool where Sarah had been prior to her disappearance. An elderly man was also seen emerging from the weeds near where her body was ultimately found. Neither of these men were identified and descriptions of them were too limited to zero in on anyone in particular. Sarah Boucher's murder bore obvious similarities to that of April Tinsley. Investigators fronting the Tinsley case took on the file, considering the possibility that they were dealing with a serial child killer,
下了一场大雨。如果她的尸体上或周围有任何外源性毛发、纤维或DNA，现在也已经被冲走了。目击者的描述并没有提供更多帮助。有报道称在莎拉失踪前，游泳池附近有一名老年男子。在最终发现她尸体的地方附近的杂草中，也看到了一名老年男子。这些男子都没有被确认身份，对他们的描述也太有限，无法锁定任何特定的人。莎拉·鲍克的谋杀案与艾普丽尔·廷斯利的谋杀案有明显的相似之处。负责廷斯利案的调查人员接手了这份档案，考虑他们可能正在处理一名连环儿童杀手，
one who took pleasure in taunting them. Just like in the Tinsley case, appeals for information failed to generate any significant leads. The Boucher and Tinsley cases languished together for two years, until police received a much-needed breakthrough. To Sarah Balka, Ron Hensley was grandpa, even though they weren't related. Hensley was the grandfather of a close family friend, and Sarah often encountered him at various events such as sleepovers, dinners, and on vacation. Hensley was such a presence in Sarah's life that he brought her presence in the form of toys and clothes and encouraged her to quote, just call me grandpa. Hensley had fought in World War II and his neck was badly
一个以嘲弄他们为乐的人。就像在廷斯利案中一样，寻求信息的呼吁未能产生任何重大线索。鲍克案和廷斯利案一起搁置了两年，直到警方收到了一个急需的突破。对莎拉·鲍克来说，罗恩·亨斯利（Ron Hensley）是爷爷，尽管他们没有血缘关系。亨斯利是一位亲密家庭朋友的祖父，莎拉经常在各种活动中遇到他，如过夜、晚餐和度假。亨斯利在莎拉的生活中非常活跃，他以玩具和衣服的形式给她带来礼物，并鼓励她引用：“就叫我爷爷。”亨斯利曾参加过第二次世界大战，他的脖子在
injured when a shell landed in his machine gun nest. He suffered post-traumatic stress disorder as a result. Whenever he heard anything akin to gunfire, explosive blasts or air raid sirens, he would cry and shake. For a time, Hensley was hospitalised in a psychiatric unit for depression and suicidal thoughts. Outside of this trauma, he maintained a charismatic and jovial facade. But he was also known as someone who made women uncomfortable by being overly touchy. He was asked to stop attending church because of the way he interacted with young girls. In December 1992, Hensley left Fort Wayne after a woman accused him of molesting her daughter. He relocated to South Carolina where he lived amongst friends and family until December 1994 when he died of lung problems at age 75.
一颗炮弹落在他的机枪巢时受了重伤。他因此患上了创伤后应激障碍。每当他听到类似枪声、爆炸声或空袭警报的声音时，他就会哭泣和颤抖。有一段时间，亨斯利因抑郁和自杀念头被送进精神病房住院。在这种创伤之外，他保持着一种富有魅力和愉快的假象。但他也被认为是一个通过过度亲昵让女性感到不舒服的人。他被要求停止去教堂，因为他与年轻女孩互动的方式。1992年12月，在一名女子指控他猥亵她的女儿后，亨斯利离开了韦恩堡。他搬到了南卡罗来纳州，在那里与朋友和家人住在一起，直到1994年12月因肺部疾病去世，享年75岁。
After Ron Hensley's death, those who knew him began sorting out his affairs. His belongings were rifled through and a shoebox was discovered. It was full of small notepads covered in Hensley's handwriting. His expansive written works turned out to be detailed accounts of crimes he had committed against countless juveniles. One tiny notebook detailed the murder of Sarah Bowker. It featured details that only her killer could have known. The notebooks were surrendered to police and given to the detectives overseeing the Bauker case. They compared Hensley's writings to the facts of the
罗恩·亨斯利去世后，那些认识他的人开始整理他的事务。他的财物被翻了个底朝天，发现了一个鞋盒。里面装满了写满亨斯利笔迹的小记事本。他大量的书面作品竟然是他对自己对无数未成年人犯下的罪行的详细记录。一个小笔记本详细记录了莎拉·鲍克的谋杀案。它包含了只有她的杀手才知道的细节。这些笔记本被上交给了警方，并交给了负责鲍克案的侦探。他们将亨斯利的文字与
crime and had no doubt. It was clear he had done it. Ron Hensley was publicly named as Sarah Boucher's killer. There would be no justice as he had died 14 months prior. Investigators nevertheless officially closed the Boucher case file. However, April Tinsley's remained open. While police weren't confirming any connections between the cases. The public couldn't help but wonder. Ron Hensley had lived about three miles from the Tinsley home at the time of April's murder. According to Hensley's son and a woman who had lived with Hensley for several years, he donated money to help fund both girls' funerals. He also allegedly carried pictures of the two girls in a keychain and visited their graves often. Janet Tinsley didn't believe Ron Hensley, a stranger to her family,
犯罪事实进行了对比，毫无疑问。很明显是他干的。罗恩·亨斯利被公开点名为莎拉·鲍克的杀手。由于他在14个月前就已经去世，正义将无法得到伸张。尽管如此，调查人员还是正式关闭了鲍克案的档案。然而，艾普丽尔·廷斯利的案件仍然开放。虽然警方没有确认这些案件之间的任何联系。公众不禁感到好奇。罗恩·亨斯利在艾普丽尔被谋杀时住在距离廷斯利家大约三英里的地方。据亨斯利的儿子和一名与亨斯利同居多年的女子说，他捐钱帮助资助了两个女孩的葬礼。他还据称在钥匙扣上带着两个女孩的照片，并经常去她们的坟墓。珍妮特·廷斯利不相信罗恩·亨斯利，一个对她家来说的陌生人，
was responsible for her daughter's murder. Detectives working the case shared her skepticism and kept looking into it. But as time wore on without any further actions or words from April's killer, speculation ran rife. For those willing to believe in Ron Hensley's guilt, it seemed awfully suspicious that April's communicative killer had fallen completely silent after Hensley died. Over a decade later, in May 2004, seven-year-old Emily Higgs found a plastic bag in the basket of her pink bicycle. It contained a used condom and a letter claiming to be from April Tinsley's killer, threatening that Emily would be his next victim. The Higgs family lived in Grable, a small town 16 miles north of Fort Wayne.
应对她女儿的谋杀负责。负责此案的侦探们也持有同样的怀疑态度，并继续进行调查。但随着时间的推移，艾普丽尔的杀手没有再采取任何行动或发表任何言论，猜测四起。对于那些愿意相信罗恩·亨斯利有罪的人来说，艾普丽尔那个健谈的杀手在亨斯利死后完全沉默了，这看起来非常可疑。十多年后的2004年5月，七岁的艾米丽·希格斯在她的粉色自行车篮子里发现了一个塑料袋。里面有一个用过的避孕套和一封信，声称来自艾普丽尔·廷斯利的杀手，威胁说艾米丽将是他的下一个受害者。希格斯一家住在格雷布尔，这是一个位于韦恩堡以北16英里的小镇。
They weren't around in 1988 when April was murdered, but after learning of the case, they contacted authorities. The police were immediately struck by the similarities between the letter Emily received and the writing April's killer scribbled on the Schwarz Road barn 14 years earlier. Not only was the handwriting the same, but they featured the same misspellings, poor grammar, and punctuation errors. Worse still, Emily Higgs wasn't the only local girl who'd received a troubling letter that week. Two other girls aged five and nine found disturbing handwritten letters on lined yellow paper. One was placed in a basket used as a flower pot, the other had been taped to the girl's bicycle. Each began with the greeting,
1988年艾普丽尔被谋杀时他们并不在那里，但在了解了案件后，他们联系了当局。警方立即被艾米丽收到的信件与艾普丽尔的杀手14年前在施瓦茨路谷仓上潦草写下的文字之间的相似之处所震惊。不仅笔迹相同，而且它们都有相同的拼写错误、语法和标点错误。更糟糕的是，艾米丽·希格斯并不是那个星期唯一收到令人不安信件的当地女孩。另外两个分别五岁和九岁的女孩在黄色横线纸上发现了令人不安的手写信件。一封被放在一个用作花盆的篮子里，另一封被贴在女孩的自行车上。每一封都以问候语开头，
Hi Honey, and featured death rats in the same mistake-riddled handwriting. In one, April's name was spelled A-P-R-O-I-L and in another, the first D in kidnapped was missing. They all also contained the words, ha ha. The three girls were given what the author referred to in his letters as a present – a used condom. The biological material these contained was tested and was found to be a 100% match to the semen sample collected from April Tinsley's underwear 16 years earlier. There was no doubt, Ron Hensley could not have been responsible for April's murder. The killer was still alive and had resurfaced again.
“亲爱的”，并以同样充满错误的笔迹写着死亡威胁。其中一封，艾普丽尔的名字被拼写为A-P-R-O-I-L，另一封中，“kidnapped”中的第一个D不见了。它们也都包含了“哈哈”这两个字。这三个女孩得到了作者在信中称为“礼物”的东西——一个用过的避孕套。这些避孕套中包含的生物材料经过了测试，被发现与16年前从艾普丽尔·廷斯利内衣中采集的精液样本100%匹配。毫无疑问，罗恩·亨斯利不可能对艾普丽尔的谋杀负责。杀手还活着，并且再次浮出水面。
His DNA was run through state and national police databases to no result. Just as investigators were examining the letters, a fourth was sent. It was found in a letterbox outside the home of a young girl and was the most personal note of all. It detailed the horrible assault the author intended to commit against his victim. This letter didn't include a condom. Instead, its present was a Polaroid photograph which depicted the naked lower torso of a white man as he lay on a bed masturbating. A bedspread with a unique green paisley-type pattern was visible in the image, but little else. Investigators checked local hotels and lodgings, but none had the bedding from the photo.
他的DNA在州和国家警察数据库中进行了比对，没有结果。就在调查人员检查这些信件时，第四封信被寄出了。它是在一个年轻女孩家门外的信箱里发现的，是所有信件中最私人的一封。它详细描述了作者打算对受害者实施的可怕袭击。这封信没有包含避孕套。相反，它的礼物是一张宝丽来照片，照片描绘了一个白人男子躺在床上自慰时裸露的下半身。照片中可以看到一条带有独特绿色佩斯利花纹的床罩，但除此之外别无他物。调查人员检查了当地的酒店和住宿，但没有一家有照片中的床上用品。
This led police to assume the picture was taken inside the man's own home. Investigators were again at a crossroads. If they'd published the letters to request the public's help, then they'd be giving the killer what he wanted – more fear and notoriety. As far as the police were aware, the killer had failed to act on his previous threat made on the barn in 1990, but that didn't necessarily mean he was sitting idly by. This time he could be ready to strike. After all, he had seemingly chosen new victims. By giving in and granting him infamy, would they embolden him to act? me. Would they embolden him to act?" Detectives sat on the letters for two years. During that time, the killer didn't appear to strike again.
这让警方推测照片是在该男子的家中拍摄的。调查人员再次陷入了僵局。如果他们公布这些信件以寻求公众帮助，那么他们就会满足凶手的愿望——带来更多的恐惧和恶名。据警方所知，凶手并没有对他1990年在谷仓留下的威胁采取行动，但这并不一定意味着他坐以待毙。这一次，他可能已经准备好下手了。毕竟，他似乎已经选择了新的受害者。如果他们屈服并让他出名，这会助长他采取行动吗？他们会助长他采取行动吗？侦探们将这些信件搁置了两年。在此期间，凶手似乎没有再次作案。
In 2006, at yet another standstill, police released samples from the killer's letters as well as cropped images of his bedspread, hoping to kickstart a manhunt. as well as cropped images of his bedspread, hoping to kickstart a manhunt. These updates led to a wave of fear washing over Fort Wayne. Not only was April Tinsley's killer still out there, but he'd been actively stalking local girls, honing in on his next victim. When Gareth Evans, not his real name, saw the notes being circulated by the media, he couldn't help but wonder. Back in 1988, Gareth's father David, also not his real name, had driven a blue pickup truck and lived within blocks of Hoagland Avenue. Curiously, in the days after April's murder, he had spray painted his truck a different colour. Since then, he had become a registered sex offender
2006年，在又一次陷入僵局时，警方公布了凶手信件的样本以及他床罩的裁剪图像，希望能启动搜捕行动。这些更新导致一股恐惧浪潮席卷了韦恩堡。不仅艾普丽尔·廷斯利的凶手仍然逍遥法外，而且他一直在积极跟踪当地女孩，锁定他的下一个受害者。当加雷斯·埃文斯（化名）看到媒体传播的这些笔记时，他不禁感到疑惑。早在1988年，加雷斯的父亲大卫（化名）就开着一辆蓝色皮卡车，住在霍格兰大道附近。奇怪的是，在艾普丽尔遇害后的几天里，他把卡车喷成了另一种颜色。从那时起，他已成为一名注册性犯罪者。
for crimes against children. He often greeted women and girls by saying, hi honey, and was prone to saying, ha ha. He also took lewd photos of himself with a Polaroid camera. Gareth contacted police to implicate his father David in the murder of April Tinsley. During questioning, David denied knowing April personally but recalled that his daughter used to play with her. Although he admitted to having owned a blue pickup truck, David said he'd sold it to a neighbour shortly before April's murder and the neighbour was responsible for painting it. When asked to provide the neighbour's details, David only gave a first name. He said he didn't know the last. David claimed that he'd been working on Friday April 1 1988, the day April was abducted.
因针对儿童的犯罪。他经常用“嗨，亲爱的”来问候妇女和女孩，并且容易说“哈哈”。他还用宝丽来相机拍摄自己的淫秽照片。加雷斯联系了警方，指控他的父亲大卫谋杀了艾普丽尔·廷斯利。在审讯中，大卫否认认识艾普丽尔，但回忆起他的女儿过去常和她一起玩。虽然他承认拥有一辆蓝色皮卡车，但大卫说他在艾普丽尔遇害前不久把它卖给了一位邻居，而那位邻居负责给它喷漆。当被要求提供邻居的详细信息时，大卫只给出了一个名字。他说他不知道姓氏。大卫声称他在1988年4月1日星期五，即艾普丽尔被绑架的那天，一直在工作。
His confident assertion immediately stood out to investigators. How could David immediately remember what he was doing 16 years earlier on a specific day? They spoke to his employer and discovered David had not worked on April 1. He also wasn't working on Monday April 4, the day April's body was found. Investigators obtained a search warrant for David's home where they discovered a notepad with lined yellow paper and a Polaroid camera. yellow paper and a Polaroid camera. Investigators were certain they had finally found their man. All they needed was David's DNA to confirm it. They collected a sample from David. To their shock, it wasn't a match for April's killer. With that, they were back at square one. The publicity about the killer's recent activities had failed to generate the leads investigators were hoping for. Detectives who had been working the case for years were starting to suffer. They struggled to sleep and became obsessed by the desire for justice.
他自信的断言立即引起了调查人员的注意。大卫怎么能立即记得16年前特定的一天他在做什么？他们与他的雇主交谈，发现大卫在4月1日并没有工作。他在4月4日星期一，即发现艾普丽尔尸体的那天，也没有工作。调查人员获得了搜查大卫家的搜查令，在那里他们发现了一个带横线的黄色记事本和一台宝丽来相机。调查人员确信他们终于找到了目标。他们只需要大卫的DNA来确认。他们采集了大卫的样本。令他们震惊的是，这与艾普丽尔的凶手不匹配。至此，他们又回到了原点。关于凶手近期活动的宣传未能产生调查人员所希望的线索。多年来一直负责此案的侦探们开始备受煎熬。他们难以入睡，并被对正义的渴望所困扰。
obsessed by the desire for justice. April's case was always at the forefront of their minds. Three kept a picture of the eight-year-old on them at all times, while another had her photo on his desk at home. Whenever they weren't working on regular duties, they pulled out the Tinsley case file. It was maddening. They felt they had what they needed to catch the guy, he had even willingly provided them with significant evidence. They just couldn't link it to anyone. Many detectives ultimately left the unit or retired without closure. But the case was never given up on. There always remained hope that a breakthrough would eventually materialise. Even as the years started to once again wear on without any further action from April Tinsley's killer. By 2009, believing the case was highly solvable, the Federal Bureau of Investigation officially
被对正义的渴望所困扰。艾普丽尔的案件始终占据着他们思想的前沿。三个人随身带着这个八岁女孩的照片，而另一个人则把她的照片放在家里的桌子上。每当他们不处理日常工作时，他们就会拿出廷斯利案的卷宗。这令人抓狂。他们觉得他们已经掌握了抓住那家伙所需的一切，他甚至自愿提供了重要证据。只是他们无法将其与任何人联系起来。许多侦探最终离开了该部门或在没有结案的情况下退休。但这个案子从未被放弃。人们始终怀有希望，认为最终会出现突破。即使随着岁月流逝，艾普丽尔·廷斯利的凶手依然没有进一步行动。到2009年，联邦调查局认为该案极易侦破，正式
stepped in. Their behavioural analysis unit created a comprehensive profile of the suspect, whom they believed was now aged in his 40s or 50s. They referred to him as a preferential child sex offender. This meant he had a long- term and persistent sexual desire for children, specifically little girls, and that interest would not go away. He could be married, but the vast majority of preferential child sex offenders were not. If he was married, his partner might be aware of his interest in girls, but in denial about the extent of
介入。他们的行为分析部门为嫌疑人建立了一份全面的档案，他们认为嫌疑人现在年龄在40多岁或50多岁。他们称他为偏好型儿童性犯罪者。这意味着他对儿童，特别是小女孩，有着长期且持续的性欲望，这种兴趣不会消失。他可能已婚，但绝大多数偏好型儿童性犯罪者并未结婚。如果他已婚，他的伴侣可能知道他对女孩的兴趣，但否认这种兴趣的程度或他采取行动的意愿。
his interest or his willingness to act on it. Although the killer was probably socially awkward, he would endeavour to build relationships that gave him access to girls, or he might seek out employment or volunteer activities that provided proximity to them. He was drawn to places where children gathered, such as playgrounds, swimming pools, and parks. Quote, wherever he goes, if a little girl is nearby, his eyes will follow her. The FBI profile warned. This offender has demonstrated that he has strong ties to North East Fort Wayne and to Allen County. This is where he likely lives, works, and or shops. You may be sitting beside him in the Pua Church, working beside him on the production line, or standing next to him in line at the grocery store.
虽然凶手可能在社交上很笨拙，但他会努力建立能让他接触到女孩的关系，或者他可能会寻找能让他接近女孩的工作或志愿者活动。他被儿童聚集的地方所吸引，例如游乐场、游泳池和公园。“无论他去哪里，如果附近有一个小女孩，他的目光就会跟随她，”联邦调查局的档案警告说。“该罪犯已证明他与韦恩堡东北部和艾伦县有很强的联系。这就是他可能居住、工作和/或购物的地方。你可能正坐在教堂里他旁边，在生产线上和他一起工作，或者在杂货店排队时站在他旁边。”
Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Casefile is thrilled to announce that all five Casefile Presents series, The Detective's Dilemma, The Vanishing of Vivian Cameron, Labyrinth, Searching for Sarah McDermid and Maddie, once exclusive to Spotify, are now accessible on all podcast platforms. These Casefile Presents series feature stories from various corners of the globe told by different narrators. Through its narratives, Casefile aims to bring these cases and instances of wrongdoing to the forefront, sparking awareness and helping the victims and their families to be remembered.
Casefile节目稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本期节目的赞助商来支持我们。Casefile很高兴地宣布，所有五个Casefile Presents系列节目——《侦探的困境》、《薇薇安·卡梅伦的失踪》、《迷宫》、《寻找莎拉·麦克德米德》和《麦迪》，曾经是Spotify独家内容，现在可以在所有播客平台上收听。这些Casefile Presents系列节目讲述了来自全球各地的故事，由不同的叙述者讲述。通过这些叙述，Casefile旨在将这些案件和不法行为推向公众视野，激发意识，并帮助人们铭记受害者及其家人。
Listen to the previously exclusive Casefile Presents series now, wherever you get your podcasts. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Case was distributed to prisons across the United States. Each card highlighted a cold case, with April Tinsley appearing on the Seven of Hearts. It was hoped that an inmate somewhere might hold key information about the crime, but no leads were generated. Meanwhile, the case was covered on a segment of the weekly television program America's Most Wanted. While this exposure attracted
现在，无论您在哪里收听播客，都可以收听之前独家的Casefile Presents系列节目。感谢您收听本期节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持了Case（案件）被分发到美国各地的监狱。每张卡片都重点介绍了一起悬案，艾普丽尔·廷斯利出现在红心7上。人们希望某个地方的囚犯可能掌握有关该犯罪的关键信息，但没有产生任何线索。与此同时，该案件在每周电视节目《美国头号通缉犯》的一个片段中进行了报道。虽然这次曝光吸引了
more tips than any other story on the show that night, it didn't relaunch the investigation. The show re-examined the case again three years later, at which point they revealed a piece of information that the police had kept secret from the public. Found a few feet from April Tinsley's body was a bag from the department store Sears. Inside was an adult toy made of wood that worked manually via a hand crank. Detectives withheld this discovery, believing it to be incriminating information that would help them identify April's killer. But they were desperate, and decided to publicise the obscure object now in the hope someone
比当晚节目中任何其他故事都多的线索，但它并没有重启调查。三年后，该节目再次重新审视了此案，当时他们透露了一条警方一直对公众保密的信息。在距离艾普丽尔·廷斯利尸体几英尺远的地方发现了一个西尔斯百货公司的袋子。里面有一个木制的成人玩具，通过手摇曲柄手动操作。侦探们隐瞒了这一发现，认为这是有助于他们识别艾普丽尔凶手的罪证信息。但他们绝望了，决定现在公开这个晦涩的物体，希望有人
might recognise it. Show host John Walsh held up a photo of April and told viewers, Look at this picture. Just look at this girl. Now think about this. Somebody kidnapped her, raped her, and murdered her. There's no telling how many other children this killer may have taken from this world. This guy is a monster. He's a coward. He's out there. More than likely, he's in this area. Somebody's got to have the courage to come forward and say, I can't look at this face and not do the right thing by leaving a tip. But the breakthrough detectives were desperate for didn't arrive.
能认出它。节目主持人约翰·沃尔什举起艾普丽尔的照片告诉观众：“看看这张照片。看看这个女孩。现在想想这个。有人绑架了她，强奸了她，并谋杀了她。不知道这个凶手可能还从这个世界上夺走了多少其他孩子。这家伙是个怪物。他是个懦夫。他在外面。很有可能，他就在这个地区。必须有人有勇气站出来说，我不能看着这张脸而不通过提供线索来做正确的事。”但侦探们渴望的突破并没有到来。
But the breakthrough detectives were desperate for didn't arrive. In 2015, the Fort Wayne community rallied together to create a memorial park in April's honor called April's Garden. Over the years that followed, events were periodically held at the park to revive awareness about the case. April's mother Janet was often in attendance, haunted by the lack of answers. During one event she told the crowd, I never thought it would go this long. Investigators revealed that at this stage they were still receiving roughly five to seven tips about the case each week. But the leads gradually fizzled out, with one FBI agent remarking, nothing's breaking, there's nothing new. The media routinely ran stories about the crime, making it the highest profile unsolved case in
但侦探们渴望的突破并没有到来。2015年，韦恩堡社区联合起来，以艾普丽尔的名义创建了一个纪念公园，名为“艾普丽尔花园”。在随后的几年里，公园里定期举办活动，以唤起人们对该案件的关注。艾普丽尔的母亲珍妮特经常出席，被缺乏答案所困扰。在一次活动中，她告诉人群：“我从没想过会持续这么久。”调查人员透露，现阶段他们每周仍会收到大约五到七条关于此案的线索。但线索逐渐减少，一位联邦调查局特工评论道：“没有任何进展，没有什么新的东西。”媒体经常报道关于这起犯罪的故事，使其成为印第安纳州最受关注的悬案。
Indiana. By the late 2010s, more than 700 suspects had had their DNA tested. This was a massive undertaking, with police required to prove probable cause for every individual who refused to provide a sample willingly. Hopes were often raised, only for a seemingly likely suspect to be ruled out by DNA. Investigators couldn't help but wonder if the killer had passed away and they were literally chasing a ghost. When asked if they would ever know for sure who killed April Tinsley, a detective replied, Eventually, I believe so. We'll get to the bottom of it." By now, the killer's original DNA sample from the crime scene in 1988 had been used up and the rest degraded. But because he had provided more samples in the used condoms he sent in 2004, there was more than enough DNA in pristine condition for investigators to work with as forensic technology evolved. Fort Wayne detectives sent the samples from April Tinsley's killer to
到2010年代末，已有700多名嫌疑人接受了DNA检测。这是一项艰巨的任务，警方必须为每一个拒绝自愿提供样本的个人证明合理怀疑。希望常常被点燃，却又因为一个看似可能的嫌疑人被DNA排除而破灭。调查人员不禁怀疑凶手是否已经去世，他们实际上是在追逐一个幽灵。当被问及他们是否会确定是谁杀害了艾普丽尔·廷斯利时，一名侦探回答说：“最终，我相信会的。我们会查个水落石出。”到目前为止，凶手在1988年犯罪现场留下的原始DNA样本已经用尽，其余的也已降解。但由于他在2004年寄出的避孕套中提供了更多样本，随着法医技术的发展，调查人员有足够多处于原始状态的DNA可以使用。韦恩堡侦探将艾普丽尔·廷斯利凶手的样本送到了
DNA technology company Parabon Nano Labs, who specialised in using genetic genealogy to investigate cold cases. Through the use of DNA phenotyping which predicts a person's appearance based on their DNA, they were able to ascertain several of the killer's observable traits. These included his eye, hair and skin colour, and even how many freckles he'd have on his face. The results were not absolute, but established the highest probability of his specific characteristics. It enabled the creation of two digital composite sketches that were as accurate as possible, one of what the suspect would have looked like in 1988 and the other aged to demonstrate his current appearance. Both depicted a fair-skinned man with brown hair and hazel or green coloured eyes. Both matched the
DNA技术公司Parabon Nano Labs，该公司专门利用基因谱系学调查悬案。通过使用基于DNA预测个人外貌的DNA表型分析，他们能够确定凶手的一些可观察特征。这些特征包括他的眼睛、头发和皮肤颜色，甚至他脸上有多少雀斑。结果并非绝对，但确定了他特定特征的最高概率。这使得创建两张尽可能准确的数字合成素描成为可能，一张是嫌疑人在1988年的样子，另一张是模拟他当前外貌的衰老图。两者都描绘了一个皮肤白皙、棕色头发、淡褐色或绿色眼睛的男子。两者都与
original 1988 sketch of the man driving the blue pickup truck that was seen approaching April. Still, he remained unrecognisable to the Tinsleys and the greater Fort Wayne community. It appeared investigators had reached yet another dead end. Then, as covered in episode 53 of Case File, the trajectory of decades-long cold cases drastically altered in 2018 when the Golden State Killer was finally apprehended after 44 years. The breakthrough came via a public genealogy website called Jedmatch. Jedmatch customers voluntarily submitted saliva swabs in exchange for an ancestry report based on their genetic profile. They could then connect with family members and distant relatives via online databases.
1988年那张驾驶蓝色皮卡车接近艾普丽尔的男子的原始素描相符。然而，对于廷斯利一家和更广泛的韦恩堡社区来说，他仍然无法辨认。调查人员似乎又走进了死胡同。然后，正如Case File第53集所报道的那样，2018年，在“金州杀手”潜逃44年后终于被捕，这改变了长达数十年的悬案轨迹。这一突破来自一个名为Jedmatch的公共基因谱系网站。Jedmatch客户自愿提交唾液拭子，以换取基于其基因图谱的祖先报告。然后，他们可以通过在线数据库与家庭成员和远房亲戚建立联系。
Similarly, investigators fronting the Golden State Killer case uploaded his DNA to the same databases with the intention of identifying him through his familial lineage. And it worked. his familial lineage. And it worked. This new investigative tool was a game changer for law enforcement. It opened a new line of inquiry for many old cold cases, including the unsolved murder of April Tinsley. Two weeks after the major breakthrough in the Golden State Killer case, detectives had Parabon Nanolabs upload April's killer's DNA on theJetmatch.com.
同样，负责“金州杀手”案件的调查人员将他的DNA上传到相同的数据库，旨在通过他的家族血统来识别他。而且成功了。这一新的调查工具对执法部门来说是一个游戏规则的改变者。它为许多旧悬案开辟了新的调查方向，包括艾普丽尔·廷斯利未侦破的谋杀案。在“金州杀手”案件取得重大突破两周后，侦探们让Parabon Nanolabs将艾普丽尔凶手的DNA上传到了Jedmatch.com。
The work was overseen by Cece Moore, the head of Parabon Nanolabs' genetic genealogy unit. In her television series, The Genetic Detective, Cece explained that at the start of an investigation she performed a personal assessment as to how likely it was that genetic genealogy would lead to the suspect's identity. She ranked the difficulty between 1 being extremely promising and 5 being pretty much impossible. For Cece, the Tinsley case ranked 4+. Within eight hours, the website had found the man's relatives, which were mostly third cousins and beyond. Cece determined two of the relatives were siblings and they formed the starting point. She scoured public records of obituaries,
这项工作由Parabon Nanolabs基因谱系部门负责人西西·摩尔监督。在她的电视系列节目《基因侦探》中，西西解释说，在调查开始时，她会进行个人评估，判断基因谱系学导致嫌疑人身份的可能性有多大。她将难度分为1到5级，1代表极有希望，5代表几乎不可能。对于廷斯利案，西西将其评为4+。在八小时内，该网站找到了该男子的亲属，主要是三代堂表亲及更远的关系。西西确定其中两名亲属是兄弟姐妹，他们构成了起点。她搜寻了讣告的公共记录，
marriage licenses and birth announcements to fill in the blanks and facilitate a family tree. The top of the family tree was filled in first, which encompassed the subject's ancestors from the 1800s. The tree expanded from there, moving forward in time and identifying each descendant along the way. At one point, Cece reached a couple that had had 11 children. Not only did she have to identify them, but all of their descendants to see if the suspect was among them. It was a long and painstaking process, but Cece was determined and wasn't going to give up. Eventually, she uncovered a couple who had three sons by 1961. At that point, they moved from their home in Florida to Fort Wayne, Indiana. By 2004, when April Tinsley's killer left the threatening ladders, one of their sons had
结婚证和出生公告，以填补空白并构建家谱。家谱的顶部首先被填满，其中包括该主体1800年代的祖先。家谱从那里扩展开来，随着时间的推移，识别沿途的每一位后代。有一次，西西找到了一对育有11个孩子的夫妇。她不仅要识别他们，还要识别他们所有的后代，看看嫌疑人是否在其中。这是一个漫长而艰苦的过程，但西西很坚定，不会放弃。最终，她发现了一对夫妇，他们在1961年之前有三个儿子。那时，他们从佛罗里达的家中搬到了印第安纳州的韦恩堡。到2004年，当艾普丽尔·廷斯利的凶手留下威胁信时，他们的一个儿子已经
passed away. C.C. Moore zeroed in on the two surviving sons. 59-year-old John Miller lived alone at a trailer park in the small town of Grable, 16 miles northeast of Fort Wayne. Miller was a loner who'd lived in the same trailer since he was 19. He kept to himself and never said hello to anyone. He never had a girlfriend, and during his few fleeting encounters with neighbours, his expression was mean and his comments were laced with profanities. At a fibreglass factory where Miller had once worked, he was known for his bad hygiene, lack of friendships, and his short temper. In fact, he had been fired for punching and breaking the time clock. At home, Miller's neighbour had seen him throw his lawnmower in a fit.
去世了。西西·摩尔将目标锁定在两名幸存的儿子身上。59岁的约翰·米勒独自住在格雷布尔小镇的一个拖车公园里，距离韦恩堡东北16英里。米勒是个独行侠，从19岁起就一直住在同一个拖车里。他独来独往，从不和任何人打招呼。他从未有过女朋友，在与邻居为数不多的短暂接触中，他的表情很刻薄，言语中夹杂着脏话。在米勒曾经工作过的一家玻璃纤维工厂，他以卫生习惯差、没有朋友和脾气暴躁而闻名。事实上，他曾因殴打并打坏考勤钟而被解雇。在家里，米勒的邻居曾看到他发脾气时扔掉割草机。
Miller's family believed his anger stemmed from being bullied during his youth. It impacted him so drastically that he ended up in a reform school. His family also suspected he was sexually abused. After losing his factory job, Miller began working at a Walmart a 30 minute drive away in the city of Kendallville, where he was rosted on the overnight shift stacking the electronics department. His colleagues, who nicknamed him John John, knew little about him. He walked around the store hunched over, seething with rage and hardly speaking. Once, Miller was overheard beating on equipment because it wasn't working right. Whenever other staff or customers asked him for help, he'd complain about it.
米勒的家人认为他的愤怒源于年轻时遭受的欺凌。这对他影响极大，以至于他最终进了感化学校。他的家人还怀疑他曾受到性虐待。失去工厂工作后，米勒开始在30分钟车程外的肯德尔维尔市的一家沃尔玛工作，他在那里被安排在夜班，负责电子产品部门的理货。他的同事们给他起了个绰号叫“约翰·约翰”，对他知之甚少。他在店里走来走去，弓着背，怒火中烧，几乎不说话。有一次，米勒被听到殴打设备，因为它工作不正常。每当其他员工或顾客向他寻求帮助时，他都会抱怨。
The only time people saw Miller outdoors was at a softball field down the street where he would watch children play. He was relatively unknown to police except for two separate incidents in 2002 and 2003 when he was reported for exhibiting lewd behaviour towards women and girls. On Sunday July 15 2018, two detectives overseeing the April Tinsley homicide investigation stood outside a faded yellow trailer at lot number 4 at the Greybull Mobile Home Park. It was a short distance from where April Tinsley's body was discovered and the barn where an ominous message from her killer was found. It was also the home of John Miller. The genetic genealogists had traced Miller through his lineage and concluded that either he or his brother was April's killer. For the past two weeks, police had covertly observed the Miller brothers at their respective
人们唯一一次在户外看到米勒是在街头的垒球场，他会在那里看孩子们玩耍。除了2002年和2003年两次因对妇女和女孩表现出淫秽行为而被举报外，警方对他知之甚少。2018年7月15日星期日，两名负责艾普丽尔·廷斯利谋杀案调查的侦探站在格雷布尔移动房屋公园4号地块一辆褪色的黄色拖车外。这里距离发现艾普丽尔·廷斯利尸体的地方和发现她凶手留下的不祥信息的谷仓很近。这也是约翰·米勒的家。基因谱系学家通过他的血统追踪了米勒，并得出结论，要么是他，要么是他的兄弟是艾普丽尔的凶手。在过去的两周里，警方一直在秘密观察米勒兄弟在各自
homes. They rarely saw John Miller when he was home, except for when he dragged his rubbish bin out to the curb. Indiana law allowed police to legally take that rubbish for evidence, as long as they had the probable cause to do so. Which they did. Officers approached the bin on foot, being as quiet as they could so Miller wouldn't be alerted to their presence. They dug through his rubbish and found a used condom. In the search for DNA evidence, this was considered
家中的情况。他们很少见到约翰·米勒在家，除非他把垃圾桶拖到路边。印第安纳州法律允许警方合法地将这些垃圾作为证据，只要他们有合理的理由这样做。他们确实有。警察步行接近垃圾桶，尽可能安静，以免米勒察觉到他们的存在。他们在他的垃圾中翻找，发现了一个用过的避孕套。在寻找DNA证据的过程中，这被认为是
a jackpot. The condom's contents were compared to the samples from April Tinsley's killer. After 30 years, they finally found a match. This resulted in a jubilant celebration not only for detectives, but all the analysts and experts who had assisted in the case. analysts and experts who had assisted in the case. Miller returned home after a brief outing to a grocery store to discover two detectives waiting for him. Upon seeing him up close, the detectives fully appreciated the accuracy of the composite sketch by Parabon Nano Labs. They introduced themselves and suggested Miller take his groceries inside, but he said no. The detectives then requested Miller's assistance with something they were working on and asked him to accompany them to Fort Wayne for questioning. He agreed.
中了大奖。避孕套的内容物与艾普丽尔·廷斯利凶手的样本进行了比对。30年后，他们终于找到了匹配。这不仅让侦探们，也让所有协助此案的分析师和专家们欢呼雀跃。米勒在去杂货店短暂停留后回到家，发现两名侦探在等他。近距离看到他时，侦探们充分体会到了Parabon Nano Labs合成素描的准确性。他们介绍了自己，并建议米勒把杂货拿进屋，但他拒绝了。侦探们随后请求米勒协助他们正在处理的事情，并要求他陪同他们前往韦恩堡接受询问。他同意了。
In the 20 minute car ride, Miller seemed to enjoy chatting about his interest in crossword puzzles and spoke of how much he liked a live PD, a television show where analysts examined the workings of US police. Miller said he never missed an episode. Once they reached the station, Miller was ushered into an interview room and read his rights. He was then told, we want to talk to you a little bit about a case that we've been working on for a while. Somebody brought your name up into this and we wanted to see what you had to say about that. Do you have any idea what we need to talk to you about? we need to talk to you about." After a moment of silence, Miller responded,
在20分钟的车程中，米勒似乎很喜欢谈论他对填字游戏的兴趣，并谈到他有多喜欢《Live PD》，这是一个由分析师检查美国警察工作的电视节目。米勒说他从不错过任何一集。到达警局后，米勒被带进审讯室并被告知了他的权利。然后他被告知：“我们想和你谈谈我们已经处理了一段时间的一个案子。有人提到了你的名字，我们想看看你对此有什么要说的。你知道我们需要和你谈什么吗？”沉默片刻后，米勒回答说：
"...I think probably the Tinsley case." The detectives were stunned, but maintained a calm and collected front. They hadn't once mentioned or alluded to April Tinsley while Miller was in their company. hadn't once mentioned or alluded to April Tinsley while Miller was in their company. Him volunteering her name of his own volition was massive. One of the detectives asked, "'What made you say the Tinsley case?' Miller thought for a moment before replying, "'DNA.'" replying. DNA. The detectives asked him to take them back to 1988. Miller drank some water before saying, I can't.
“……我想可能是廷斯利案。”侦探们惊呆了，但保持着冷静和镇定的外表。在米勒与他们在一起时，他们一次也没有提到或暗示过艾普丽尔·廷斯利。他自愿说出她的名字是非常重大的。其中一名侦探问：“是什么让你说出廷斯利案的？”米勒思考片刻后回答说：“DNA。”侦探们要求他带他们回到1988年。米勒喝了一些水后说：“我做不到。”
Sensing he wanted to speak further, the detectives encouraged him. John, it's time to get this out. You've had to have known that this day was coming." With that, Miller started talking and the floodgates opened. On the afternoon of Friday April 1 1988, Miller was in Fort Wayne looking for a child to abduct. It was a desire he'd felt for a while. He was trawling the streets in his car when he saw April Tinsley walking alone down Hoagland Avenue. Miller had never met or seen April prior to this encounter. There was no one else around, so he drove a little
感觉到他想进一步交谈，侦探们鼓励他。“约翰，是时候说出来了。你一定知道这一天会到来。”就这样，米勒开始说话，闸门打开了。1988年4月1日星期五下午，米勒在韦恩堡寻找一个孩子进行绑架。这是他感受已久的一种欲望。他开车在街上游荡时，看到艾普丽尔·廷斯利独自走在霍格兰大道上。米勒在这次相遇之前从未见过或听说过艾普丽尔。周围没有其他人，所以他开车稍微
further down the road and waited outside his vehicle as she approached. Wielding a sharp letter opener, he then confronted April, who said, Don't hurt me. I'll do whatever you say. He ordered her to get in his car. Unfortunately, the witness who happened upon the abduction as it was unfolding had made a mistake. They thought Miller had been in a blue pickup truck, when in fact he drove a blue Mercury Lynx, which was a sedan. Miller drove April straight to his trailer in Grebel, where he sexually assaulted her. During his police interview, Miller was asked why he couldn't have just released April somewhere after the attack. Miller casually replied,
沿着路往前走，在车外等待她靠近。他挥舞着一把锋利的拆信刀，随后与艾普丽尔对峙，艾普丽尔说：“别伤害我。我会做你说的任何事。”他命令她上车。不幸的是，碰巧目睹了绑架过程的证人犯了一个错误。他们以为米勒开的是一辆蓝色皮卡车，而实际上他开的是一辆蓝色水星山猫，那是一辆轿车。米勒直接把艾普丽尔带到了他在格雷布尔的拖车里，在那里他性侵了她。在警察审讯中，米勒被问及为什么在袭击后不能把艾普丽尔释放在某个地方。米勒漫不经心地回答：
I thought about it. I was afraid she'd tell. The detective pressed on, saying, pressed on saying, "'But April didn't even know you.'" Miller didn't reply and just silently stared blankly ahead, his mouth agape. Miller had choked April to death to prevent her from speaking out about the assault. The process took 10 minutes. He molested her once more, then drove to County Road 68 in the early hours of the morning and left April's body in the ditch. The next day, Sunday, he realised that one of April's shoes was in his car. He drove past where he'd left her body and tossed the shoe out the window as he sped away. April wouldn't be discovered until the Monday, three days after she was taken. From then on, Miller kept a low profile.
“我想过。我怕她会说出去。”侦探继续追问，说：“但艾普丽尔甚至不认识你。”米勒没有回答，只是默默地盯着前方，嘴巴张开。米勒掐死了艾普丽尔，以防止她说出袭击的事。这个过程持续了10分钟。他又猥亵了她一次，然后在凌晨开车到68号县道，把艾普丽尔的尸体扔在沟里。第二天，星期天，他意识到艾普丽尔的一只鞋在车里。他开车经过他留下她尸体的地方，在加速离开时把鞋扔出了窗外。艾普丽尔直到周一，也就是她被带走三天后才被发现。从那时起，米勒一直保持低调。
He remained living in the same trailer park, but stayed a very private person. He did the same thing day in, day out, went to work during the quiet midnight shift and returned straight home. Occasionally he'd go out for breakfast at the local inn where he was in the presence of many people including Grable's town council president. Yet he offered a little else to others aside from a grunt when they said hello. No one in the community came close to knowing or suspecting him at all. In the years after killing April, Miller thought about abducting another child. He scrawled the confession on the barn in 1990 and deposited threatening letters in his local area during 2004. He loitered in neighbourhoods and parking lots waiting to cross paths with another
他继续住在同一个拖车公园，但一直是一个非常私密的人。他日复一日地做同样的事情，在安静的午夜轮班期间去工作，然后直接回家。偶尔他会去当地的旅馆吃早餐，在那里他会出现在许多人面前，包括格雷布尔镇议会主席。然而，除了别人打招呼时他发出的咕哝声外，他几乎不与他人交流。社区里没有人接近了解或怀疑他。在杀害艾普丽尔后的几年里，米勒想过绑架另一个孩子。他在1990年把自白书写在谷仓上，并在2004年在他当地投放了威胁信。他在社区和停车场徘徊，等待与另一个
lone girl, but the opportunity never arose. Miller was questioned in relation to other unsolved missing or murdered children cases. He maintained he had no involvement in any, and his DNA didn't match evidence obtained from other crime scenes. After Miller's confession to the murder of April Tinsley, he was immediately taken into custody and work began in preparation for his trial. It was a laborious process. Over the years, the many investigators who worked on the case had produced boxes and boxes of information. The first month alone was spent scanning old VHS and cassette tapes to update them for digital storage. Speaking of the chance encounter April had with her killer,
落单的女孩相遇，但机会从未出现。米勒因其他未侦破的失踪或谋杀儿童案件而受到询问。他坚称自己没有参与任何案件，他的DNA与从其他犯罪现场获得的证据不匹配。在米勒承认谋杀艾普丽尔·廷斯利后，他立即被拘留，并开始为审判做准备。这是一个费力的过程。多年来，许多负责此案的调查人员制作了成箱成箱的信息。仅第一个月就花在扫描旧VHS和盒式磁带上，以便将它们更新为数字存储。谈到艾普丽尔与凶手的偶然相遇，
a case detective remarked, "...it's scary to think there are people in our society capable of doing this. Had she been five minutes earlier or five minutes later, we probably wouldn't be here today. It could have been anybody, any little kid in that area that day, and that was probably not the first time Miller had gone looking. His arrest was a huge relief to the residents of Fort Wayne, who had felt haunted by April Tinsley's killer for decades. One FBI agent praised the dedication of the case detectives, stating, This investigation illustrates the dogged determination of the investigators who never wavered, never gave up, and kept moving forward for the last 30 years.
一位案件侦探评论道：“……想到我们社会中有能够做出这种事的人，真是太可怕了。如果她早五分钟或晚五分钟，我们今天可能就不会在这里了。那天在那个地区，这可能是任何孩子，而且那可能不是米勒第一次去寻找目标。他的被捕对韦恩堡的居民来说是一个巨大的解脱，他们几十年来一直被艾普丽尔·廷斯利的凶手所困扰。一位联邦调查局特工称赞了案件侦探的奉献精神，指出：“这项调查展示了调查人员顽强的决心，他们从未动摇，从未放弃，并在过去30年里不断前进。”
In the late up to his trial, John Miller began walking unsteadily and started using a wheelchair. He appeared too feeble to handle court proceedings. Detectives were dubious, however, pointing out that no matter how frail his physical condition, Miller was mentally sound. He knew right from wrong and was fully aware of what he'd done. In the end, Miller opted to forego a trial and accepted a plea deal instead. Detectives believed he'd realised the strength of the DNA evidence was impossible to argue against. During Miller's sentencing, Janet Tinsley purposefully sat at the front of the public gallery so her daughter's killer could see her. She wanted him to see what he had destroyed. When Janet spoke,
在审判临近时，约翰·米勒开始步履蹒跚，并开始使用轮椅。他看起来太虚弱，无法处理法庭程序。然而，侦探们表示怀疑，指出无论他的身体状况多么虚弱，米勒的精神状态是健康的。他知道是非对错，并完全意识到自己做了什么。最终，米勒选择放弃审判，接受了认罪协议。侦探们认为他已经意识到DNA证据的力度是不可能反驳的。在米勒宣判期间，珍妮特·廷斯利特意坐在公众席的前排，以便她女儿的凶手能看到她。她想让他看到他摧毁了什么。当珍妮特发言时，
she described the tremendous impact that April's abduction and murder and the ensuing decades of uncertainty had made on her family. She spoke of the health problems they all faced due to stress and turmoil and how April's brother and cousins grew up sheltered and overprotected. They all developed trust issues, especially towards men. Whenever Janet went out, she found herself wondering every time she passed a man, are you him? Looking directly at Miller, she said, I'll never forgive and never forget what you took from us. For pleading guilty to criminal confinement, child molestation and felony murder, John Miller was sentenced to 80 years in prison with no chance for appeal.
她描述了艾普丽尔的绑架和谋杀以及随之而来的几十年不确定性对她家庭造成的巨大影响。她谈到了他们因压力和动荡而面临的健康问题，以及艾普丽尔的兄弟和堂兄弟姐妹是如何在受庇护和过度保护下长大的。他们都产生了信任问题，尤其是对男性的信任。每当珍妮特出门时，她发现自己每次经过一个男人时都会想：“是你吗？”直视着米勒，她说：“我永远不会原谅，也永远不会忘记你从我们这里夺走的一切。”因承认犯有非法监禁、猥亵儿童和重罪谋杀罪，约翰·米勒被判处80年监禁，不得上诉。
The deal enabled him to avoid the death penalty. Miller is due for release in July 2058, six days after his 99th birthday. For Emily Higgs, one of the children who received a threatening letter from Miller in 2004, the terror never abated. Miller lived close to her the entire time. Emily had slatted down a hill and played in a park near his home. She visited the softball fields he was known to loiter at. Her mother Crystal was grateful the torment was over. It was like, this is over with, this is over with, she said. Finally. The detectives who solved the Tinsley case received an award from the National Association of Police Organisations, which paid tribute to law enforcement officers who went above and beyond
该协议使他避免了死刑。米勒定于2058年7月获释，即他99岁生日后六天。对于2004年收到米勒威胁信的孩子之一艾米丽·希格斯来说，恐惧从未减退。米勒一直住在离她很近的地方。艾米丽曾滑下山坡，在他家附近的公园玩耍。她去过他经常徘徊的垒球场。她的母亲克里斯托很庆幸折磨结束了。“就像是，这结束了，这结束了，”她说。“终于。”侦探们解决了廷斯利案，获得了全国警察组织协会颁发的奖项，该奖项旨在表彰那些超越了
the call of duty. While investigators were glad the case was finally closed, they were puzzled by the fact that no one had ever named John Miller as a suspect. He fit the description of April's killer in every way possible – his appearance, age, location, history, behaviour and personality. Detectives were stunned that no one recognised his highly unusual handwriting or the unique bedspread he'd taken lewd polaroids against in 2004. It was ultimately settled on that this must have been due to his extremely reclusive lifestyle. April Tinsley's murder was the fifth case solved using genetic genealogy, but certainly not the last. In the words of one county prosecutor,
职责范围的执法人员。虽然调查人员很高兴案件终于结案，但他们对没有人曾将约翰·米勒列为嫌疑人感到困惑。他在各方面都符合艾普丽尔凶手的描述——他的外貌、年龄、地点、历史、行为和个性。侦探们感到震惊的是，没有人认出他非常不寻常的笔迹，或者他在2004年拍摄淫秽宝丽来照片时所用的独特床罩。最终人们认为这一定是因为他极其隐居的生活方式。艾普丽尔·廷斯利的谋杀案是第五起使用基因谱系学解决的案件，但肯定不是最后一起。用一位县检察官的话说，
today we're at a point where if you're a criminal and you've left your DNA at the scene, you may as well turn yourself in now. The previous decades had been torture for the Tinsley family. Whenever they believed an end was in sight, their hopes were dashed and they were left with the agonising realisation that the case might never be solved. After thirty years, they finally had the answers they needed, though for Janet Tinsley, true resolution would only arrive after John Miller's death. Now she finds peace by spending hours in the public garden planted on behalf of her daughter. On Sunday July 15 2018, the television series On The Case
今天我们处于这样一个地步：如果你是一个罪犯，并且你在现场留下了DNA，你现在最好还是自首吧。过去的几十年对廷斯利一家来说是一种折磨。每当他们认为终点在望时，他们的希望就会破灭，他们不得不面对案件可能永远无法解决的痛苦现实。三十年后，他们终于得到了他们需要的答案，尽管对于珍妮特·廷斯利来说，真正的解脱只有在约翰·米勒死后才会到来。现在，她通过在为她女儿种植的公共花园里度过数小时来寻找内心的平静。2018年7月15日星期日，电视系列节目《On The Case》
with Paul Azan aired an episode on April Tinsley's then unsolved murder. Janet Tinsley featured in the program, unaware that the case was about to be solved. That same day, John Miller was confronted outside his home by detectives who'd concretely linked him to April's murder. When journalist Paul Azan asked Janet what she missed most about April, Janet answered, I miss her growing up. What would she look like, act like? Would she be married? It would have been nice to see that. But my memory of her is when she was just a little girl. That's when it ends. Casefile is thrilled to announce that all five Casefile Presents series, The Detective's Dilemma, The Vanishing of Vivian Cameron, Labyrinth, Searching for Sarah McDermid and Maddie, once exclusive to Spotify, are now accessible on all podcast platforms. These Casefile Presents series feature stories from various corners of the globe told by different narrators.
与保罗·阿赞一起播出了关于艾普丽尔·廷斯利当时未侦破谋杀案的一集。珍妮特·廷斯利出现在节目中，不知道案件即将被解决。同一天，约翰·米勒在屋外被侦探们当场拦截，他们已经确凿地将他与艾普丽尔的谋杀案联系起来。当记者保罗·阿赞问珍妮特她最怀念艾普丽尔的什么时，珍妮特回答说：“我怀念她长大。她会长什么样，表现得怎么样？她会结婚吗？能看到这些会很好。但我对她的记忆是她还是个小女孩的时候。那就是结束的地方。”Casefile很高兴地宣布，所有五个Casefile Presents系列节目——《侦探的困境》、《薇薇安·卡梅伦的失踪》、《迷宫》、《寻找莎拉·麦克德米德》和《麦迪》，曾经是Spotify独家内容，现在可以在所有播客平台上收听。这些Casefile Presents系列节目讲述了来自全球各地的故事，由不同的叙述者讲述。
Through its narratives, Casefile aims to bring these cases and instances of wrongdoing to the forefront, sparking awareness and helping the victims and their families to be remembered. Listen to the previously exclusive Casefile Presents series now, wherever you get your podcasts. I want to tell you about Buried Bones, the historical true crime podcast on the Exactly Right Network. It's hosted by journalist Kate Winkler Dawson and retired investigator Paul Hulls. Case file listeners might recognise the name Paul Hulls from our six-part East Area rapist Golden State Killer series. Paul was instrumental in identifying
通过这些叙述，Casefile旨在将这些案件和不法行为推向公众视野，激发意识，并帮助人们铭记受害者及其家人。现在，无论您在哪里收听播客，都可以收听之前独家的Casefile Presents系列节目。我想向您介绍《Buried Bones》，这是Exactly Right Network上的历史真实犯罪播客。它由记者凯特·温克勒·道森和退休调查员保罗·赫尔斯主持。Case file的听众可能从我们六部分的“东区强奸犯/金州杀手”系列中认出保罗·赫尔斯这个名字。保罗在识别
Joseph D'Angelo as the perpetrator and was interviewed as part of that series. Each week Paul and Cade examine a different case from history and use their years of experience and 21st century forensics to bring new insights into these very old tragedies. Some cases are still cold and others have been resolved, but was the right person held accountable? Together, Kate and Paul break down these cases, discuss evidence and reflect on how far we've come thanks to modern forensics. Don't miss new episodes every Wednesday. Follow Buried Bones wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
约瑟夫·迪安杰洛作为肇事者方面发挥了重要作用，并作为该系列的一部分接受了采访。每周，保罗和凯特都会审视一个不同的历史案件，并利用他们多年的经验和21世纪的法医技术，为这些非常古老的悲剧带来新的见解。有些案件仍然是悬案，而另一些已经解决，但正确的人是否被追究了责任？凯特和保罗一起剖析这些案件，讨论证据，并反思由于现代法医技术，我们已经走了多远。不要错过每周三的新剧集。无论您在哪里收听播客，请关注《Buried Bones》。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。